[Music]
joining me today is the editor of spiked
online and a true free speech warrior
Brendan O'Neil finally welcome to the
Reuben reply day I've been trying to get
you for like a year and a half
you are not on Twitter what kind of
human in 2017 public and hers in editor
is I hate her I hate Twitter I think
it's become incredibly toxic yeah
and it's become it was supposed to be a
tool of free speech where you could
express yourself and say what you think
and maybe even a space on the internet
for people who have different crazy or
alternative views but in many ways
that's become the opposite it's become a
tool for shutting down free speech you
know the whole twitch phenomenon Twitter
mobs anyone who thinks outside of the
kind of mainstream liberal PC box can be
hounded quite easily yeah so I'm not a
fan of Twitter
also I have a short temper oh they do
really doing the right side I think I'd
be suited to Twitter because I would end
up getting two arguments I didn't want
to get into yeah for a free speech guy
in and an absolutist in this regard the
mobs and all that and the twitch
policing and all of that you're for them
doing all that I said you're not for
stopping them doing those things just
talking about the process yeah everyone
doing all the stuff yeah it's a
difficult one because you don't want any
clamp down or restrictions on their
right to be a mob right you want to
defend the right to form a mob and to
say things as a mob but it is it does
have an impact on freedom of speech and
freedom of thought and it's a point John
Stuart Mill makes in on Liberty John
Stuart Mill often argued that the worst
kind of censorship is not necessarily
legal or state censorship it's often
what he called the informal tyranny of
custom where there's just this
expectation that you will go along with
the conformist mainstream view and if
you don't you will in some subtle way be
punished maybe acid from polite society
may be a signal will be sent that you're
not a good person
I think the Twitter mob from phenomenon
feeds into that so in many ways it can
be a more insidious form of censorship
than even government censorship yeah
it's so interesting cuz I say all the
time now it's that at the moment and of
course this can change but at the moment
I'm not that concerned about
government censorship at the moment that
being said what I am concerned about is
that we're silencing ourselves really
because everyone is afraid of the
outrage machine and that's why I've
tried to consistently bring on people
like you who although you're not on
Twitter who are just out there doing it
and you're still alive and as Douglas
Murray said to me the water ain't that
cold you guys get out there and do it
yeah I think the worst kind of
censorship now is self censorship almost
cowardice is a strong word I think with
some people it's a cowardice of about
saying what they really think other
people with other people who said
genuine genuine fear that if they say
what they think they will be hounded or
demonized and so on self censorship is
the real danger now and there's a lot of
it going on people who are not speaking
freely and openly because they fear the
consequences and the consequences can be
quite severe you can have your workplace
hounded with email saying you should
sack this guy because he thinks a B or C
of course you can be hounded off campus
by informal gangs of feminists or PC
people or or even trans people the
government has no involvement in that
but it does nonetheless have this very
insidious profound impact on the general
freedom of society and the general sense
that everything should be sable
everything should be debatable
everything should be up for discussion
that idea is being demolished not by
government jackboots but increasingly by
these informal gangs of PC enforcers
yeah where do you think that the
companies themselves the tech companies
so Facebook Twitter YouTube etc what
responsibilities do they have because
everyone knows they have their own Terms
of Service nobody we're putting this on
YouTube nobody's forcing me to be on
YouTube nobody's forcing me to be on
Twitter again you're not on Twitter a
wise man but what responsibilities
related to free speech do you think they
have because they've booted off some
people yeah that I think are actually DC
I'm not talking about some of the you
know people that are actually making
death threats which of course is a legal
issue but they put some people like
sargon of akkad i've had on my show a
couple times they've booted him off
twitter i think they have a large
responsibility in relation to freedom of
speech and there was a Supreme Court
case in this country decades ago about
corporate towns which are these towns
bill
tap around corporations and so on and
one of these corporate towns are a few
of these corporate towns argued that
they didn't have to adhere to the First
Amendment because they were private
entities and the judgment that was made
in the Supreme Court case was that if
you are a private enterprise which is so
large that you legitimately incorporate
a huge amount of public space a huge
amount of the public sphere in which
people speak and which in which people
interact then you do actually have a
responsibility to defend freedom of
speech and I think that certainly goes
for social media companies yeah that's
interesting that's now the that's now a
public arena that's the if you look at
Facebook like a seventh of humanity is
on Facebook or Twitter millions of
people on Twitter millions and millions
of people on YouTube these are the new
public forums these are the new public
squares these are the new spaces in
which people stand up make
pronouncements get on soap boxes hand
out pamphlets engage their fellow
citizens so I think it's entirely
legitimate to expect that the same free
speech that we hope would apply in a
public square would apply in these
forums too so is there a little bit of a
problem there because we're going to
talk about your your Marxist libertarian
views in a little bit but as someone
that at least going off the second part
of that the libertarian side I know for
me the idea of having the government
come in and now tell Facebook and
YouTube
what to do even though I had my
frustrations with them I don't really
see that as the answer here what I see
is the answer is capitalism in a
competition and let other companies come
and hopefully you know give a little
competition so they have to give us a
better service but but I struggle with
this one and interestingly I see a lot
of people on the right who were supposed
to be the libertarians and limited
government guys calling for these places
to be regulated you know sort of like
they did to AT&T a year you know years
ago yeah it's a difficult one because on
the one hand you don't want the
government to tell these social media
companies to prevent people from saying
certain things which is happening in
Britain at the moment lots of
politicians are kind of ganging together
to force Twitter and other forums to
restrict certain things in a speech and
so on so you don't want that but on the
other hand you don't necessarily want
the government to force these companies
to preserve freedom of speech or
publish things that they might not want
to publish Nathan private organization
so it is difficult there's no question
about that but my preference would be
that we would encourage these kind of
companies and encourage social media
platforms to value freedom of speech in
its entirety which means freedom of
speech not only for people who we like
and who are agreeable and who are
interesting and sensible and and and
liberal and nice and so on but also for
people who are edgy and difficult and
controversial and contrary in' and maybe
even hateful on the basis that is only
by having the fullest freedom of
expression possible that we can all then
work out what we think is right and
wrong
but you know that's the only possibility
of having of arriving at any kind of
truth where everything is up for grabs
everything is stated publicly and then
you trust the audience you trust the
viewers you trust the listeners to
decide for themselves using their
autonomous minds what's good and what's
bad that's the kind of culture we need
to cultivate yeah is there a doubly
difficult problem here because also we
don't know what's going on with the
algorithms that these companies make so
publicly they could say we're for free
speech yes all these things but actually
they might be writing in code that could
you know stop some of my subscribers
from seeing videos or putting me aside
could you know wipe out people's Twitter
accounts or whatever does it's like we
actually don't know now the math behind
how people get information
unquestionably that happens and I don't
I don't have a Twitter account but I
sometimes look at to it so you can't
live in the modern sphere without
looking at it and seeing what people are
talking about on there and what amazes
me if you look at Twitter stories for
example all the things that Twitter
emphasizes it's always stuff that goes
along with the Twitter mindset with
Silicon Valley mindset with that kind of
fairly mainstream conformist mindset now
you know they they emphasize the if
Twitter has a kind of intersectional
outburst and it attacks someone for
being sexist on the sojanet or racist
and so on often overblown accusations
Twitter will emphasize that up
and turn it into the daily story so
Twitter undoubtedly has an editorial
input and control and in a sense you
want to say fine that's you can do that
but then they've got to stop calling
themselves the free speech wing of the
Free Speech Party because increasingly
they do appear like a publication just
happens to let other voices chip in
every now and then so basically what I'm
sensing from you is that there really is
no good answer here yet right because
what you're saying is you want them to
self-police you don't want the
government to come in you want them to
be transparent but you don't want to use
force to make that strap in so there
really is no answer that we can walk
away from and be like well alright
that's the sensible way to deal with it
that's not the idea that you're talking
about that way yeah I like the personal
responsibility of the individual and the
company but that's sort of separate from
what actually happens when the rubber
meets the road
yeah there's no easy answer except that
we should defend freedom of speech every
single time it's under attack whether
that's in the Academy on some informal
part of campus in relation to the
government in social media in the press
wherever freedom of speech is under
attack we should defend freedom of
speech and we should defend it for the
very simple reason that everyone should
be allowed to say what they want to say
and everyone else this is the part of
freedom of speech that people forget
because they always say oh you're
defending free speech for horrible
people
the second even more important part of
freedom of speech is defending the right
of the audience to decide for themselves
what's right and what's wrong
yeah and that's the most important part
because the problem with censorship of
course is that it infantilizes people in
tells you you don't have to think we
will think for you we will decide for
you and that really weakens people's
moral muscles weakens their intellectual
muscle muscles encourages them to be
child like an infant like and and to
never think about the world yeah if it
directly feeds out raid culture it
actually feeds a if it's a very
simplistic reader of the world a very
childish reading of the world and it
dumbs down culture censorship is a far
greater threat to
intellectualism and peace and liberty
and all those things we think are good
then freedom of speech ever could be so
it's important to always defend freedom
of speech in every sphere and through
doing that I think we might eventually
encourage people rather than forcing
them to protect freedom of speech within
the spheres in which they operate yeah
do you think we're getting some wins
right now I mean I you're doing a tour
with a bunch of people from Brett
Weinstein and Laura Kipnis and Steven
Pinker and a whole bunch of people in
this space and you know I'm doing the
college thing too and obviously spiked
is working this show is working other
people in this plate in this space it's
all working do you think we're actually
starting to win here I'm you know I'm
hopeful as a human yeah I know I'm an
optimist yeah otherwise I couldn't do
this but there's so much bad stuff it's
hard to it's hard to place it I there
between optimism and pessimism and which
are both valuable emotions as it happens
optimism is good because you feel
buoyant and you want to go out and fight
in the world and pessimism is good
because it makes you reflect and think
well what's going wrong so I don't have
a problem with either of those takes but
I flip between the two on the one hand
I'm optimistic because I see lots of
young people and on this tall that
spiders doing the unsafe space tour
whether they're on two campuses and what
we're trying to do in fact is move away
from the pantomime debates that have
been taking place on campus in recent
years where some member of the so-called
alright we'll come in and irritate all
the feminists and the idiots in the
audience and then they will you know the
alt-right gets a kick because they wind
everyone up and then the audience
members get a kick butt because they get
to shout fascist at people they don't
right and all you do is strengthen the
extreme you straighten these dreams and
it's all heat and no light and it's
entertaining and everyone watches on
YouTube and it gets hundreds of
thousands of hits but no one learns
anything so what we're trying to do with
this tour is go onto campuses and and
convince people using hopefully
intellectual rigor and and substantial
historical arguments and and clever
people yeah that freedom of speech is
the most important value in a civilized
society and in fact civilized society is
not possible without it so we're trying
as best as we can to
the discussion away from the rather
pantomime black and white unhelpful
clash that it's become the cultural war
that it's become to explain the origins
of freedom and the importance of freedom
and I'm optimistic because we've were
having a good reception and I'm meeting
young people in New York and Washington
and and other places in America who are
really really keen on freedom of speech
but feel like they don't have a place in
which they can say how keen they are on
freedom of speech yeah so I'm optimistic
in that sense I'm pessimistic in the
sense that I fear that the argument of
freedom is being colonized by people on
the right who I don't think are always a
hundred percent convincing in their
defense of freedom and the thing that
particularly worries me now is the
left's abandonment of the ideal of
freedom I think that's actually the real
crisis we face in Western societies now
which is that the left and so-called
liberals and you know the word liberal
is about the word liberty you know are
turning their backs on Liberty that's a
real problem yeah okay so I really want
to dive deep into this one because
everyone watching this at least my
audience knows that I mean this is where
I've spent most of my time you know I
came from the progressive world I wanted
to fix the left subsequently two years
later after endlessly talking about this
I did a video with Prager you which day
titled why I left left because I've come
to the position that liberalism in the
classical sense the John Stuart Mill
sense no longer has anything to do with
modern leftism yeah so let's really go
deeper yeah so first off let's start
with why are you let's start with the
roots of why liberalism should be
connected to the left let's just start
there
well the way I put it is that I didn't
leave the left the left left me because
the left abandoned everything that it
used to represent and the way I see
political correctness which is this kind
of rehabilitation of the racial
imagination so everyone is now black and
white or man and woman in this constant
divisive nurse and shoving people back
into biological boxes from which they
spent 200 years trying to escape or it's
a liberalism so it doesn't want you to
be
controversial or daring or contrarian
what's everything to be sedate or even
the modern PC people's agitation with
things like economic growth or exploring
nature or even dare I say exploiting
nature for the good of mankind on all
occasions right I mean that's super
controversial yeah all those things
suggest to me that the PC culture you
know people call it left in my mind it
runs counter to everything the left used
to stand for I think it is reactionary I
think if anything is right-wing I happen
to think left and right aren't
particularly useful the categories now
but it's certainly more right wing than
it is left wing do you might remember a
moment when it happened because that's
what a lot of people ask me they ask me
when my specific wake up was or when
your specific wake up was but do you
think there was a cultural or political
moment that really was the hammer that
kind of whacked it and then started to
go in the wrong way I think it's been a
long-standing process I think it's been
growing for a long time I think you
could even trace it back to the 60s when
the left shifts from being interested in
economic issues and the working class
towards being interested in you know the
new left interested in cultural issues
and the problem of advertising and
consumerism and so on and that shift
from being interested in production how
are things produced and who owns them
towards being obsessed with consumerism
why are we always pressured to buy
things and so on and that was a very
important shift from economy and power
towards issues of culture and then that
grows through the 70s and the 80s and it
becomes the dominant theme of the left
and you know the way I see it is that if
I look back because I still call myself
a Marxist libertarian I partly do it
just to we're gonna do it just to annoy
people
because no understands what it means
yeah even I don't understand what he
owns but I always considered the left to
be universal pro-growth that was one of
the most important parts of the left and
interested in autonomy interested in
pushing away all the priests and princes
and and bureaucrats who wanted to tell
ordinary people how to live and trusted
ordinary people more than
experts that's how I saw the left now I
see a left a so-called left that has
abandoned those three things
so it's ditched universalism in favor of
the rabbit-hole of identity politics and
the rabbit-hole of biological difference
or historical difference its ditch the
argument for economic growth in favor of
the cult of environmentalism and this
idea that every single thing we do to
the planet is destructive and maybe we
should rein in growth and homeless
growth and it's ditched the argument for
autonomy and and the shoving aside of
the bureaucrats who want to govern
ordinary people's lives in favor of
Sacre lysing expertise and celebrating
expertise and celebrating the state and
the role of the state in governing or
assisting poor people who apparently
can't cope on their own so if those are
the three spheres of left-wing politics
and I think they are which is
universalism economic growth in order to
liberate people from poverty and the
idea that people can probably run their
own lives and will make a better fist of
it than government would I think that's
what the left used to be about going
back a hundred years 150 years they've
ditched all of that and are now very Pro
stay pro identity Pro division and pro
planet over pro growth that is what
worries me so that's why I say I didn't
leave the left I still consider myself a
man of the radical left yeah it's the
left that is drifted off into a whole
new territory yeah and that's why
whatever whatever it is that we are
whatever that is yeah that thing and we
I don't even know all your political
bleeps on everything but I'm sure we
have some disagreements up but whatever
it is that we basically are is becoming
the widest tent because I see what
happened what's happening right now and
it's like we're taken in people all over
them yes that are just going I just want
to live free you know this is the
exciting thing about the period we live
in this is where I am optimistic and I'm
generally very optimistic about where
politics is going even though it goes up
and down and up and down you know I I
still consider myself a little bit of a
trotskyist right now and the reason when
I say this to right-wing friends of mine
and and kind of classical liberal
friends when they look at me in absolute
horror and then I say to them look
Trotsky was once asked what does it mean
to be a radical leftist and he said it
means you want to increase the power of
man over nature and decrease the power
of man over man
now I would live and die by them yeah
that's pretty good
that is all right I want to increase our
control of nature so that we understand
it better and we use it better in order
to end poverty and so on it's
particularly in the third world and I
want to decrease the power of man over
man fewer laws for your regulations no
censorship no bureaucracy or far less
bureaucracy so when I say that to
classical liberals and right-wing
friends of mine they they get it
instantly yeah but what's really
exciting about today is that I actually
think the new alliances that are forming
are incredibly interesting so I often
find I have far more in common even with
people on the old right or certainly
with people on the kind of classical
liberal right or the free-market right
then I do with people who today describe
themselves as left-wing I have more in
common with the religious people in
Europe who are currently defending
freedom of speech far better than some
atheists are because religious speech is
under attack in Europe so it's the new
alliances that I find incredibly
interesting and exciting and and and so
I think a new dividing line is opening
up and it's no longer the dividing line
between where do you stand on the market
or are you left-wing or right-wing it's
increasingly a dividing line over
do you trust ordinary people to run
their own lives and that sounds like a
simple question but actually cuts to the
heart of everything because if you do
trust ordinary people to run their own
lives you will be interested in
diminishing government interference
defending free speech in all instances
because you think people can make up
their own minds and diminishing
bureaucracy if you don't trust ordinary
people and tragically the left doesn't
anymore you will be in favor of growing
the welfare state growing environmental
controls restricting the expansion of
production and growth and everything
else and censoring speech
so the key dividing line I I think now
is
do you trust people yes or no it's such
an interesting distinction you're making
there because the left but if you were
just looking at this sort of from higher
up down what the messaging is it's sort
of like you know you're screwed you're
the little man and you know we so we
really care about you but what they're
really saying is give us power to
control you yeah this is these are two
very different things
and that's why I think so much of what's
happening with post-modernism and
intersectionality and all of this is
just lazy thinking yeah it sounds good
at first like oh you're gonna give more
money to poor people or we're gonna you
know if you are pressed in this way you
should link together with someone who's
oppressed in this way it all sounds kind
of like it makes sense but when you get
to that second layer it starts peeling
away pretty freaking quick this is the
really shocking thing about the left
today the left is now a movement against
working-class people and that is a
turnaround in politics which i think is
historically unprecedented the left used
to be a movement for working-class
people which meant that it understood
them or it sought to understand them it
wanted to know what they thought it
wanted to increase their power and
increase their autonomy and increase
their income that's what the left was
born to do and that's what it devoted
itself to doing for decades increasingly
what the left represents now is it's a
movement against working people so in
Britain in on the British left they now
often refer refer to poor and
working-class people as the vulnerable
and they see them as very vulnerable
people vulnerable to being exploited
vulnerable to the harsh vagaries of
everyday life
vulnerable to the spin-offs of poverty
and so on and so their argument becomes
we must protect these people we must
save these people we must help these
people and what happens then over time
is that they it's less and less about
liberating ordinary people whether it's
from the harshness of everyday life or
from the diktats of bureaucracy and it
becomes more about mollycoddling them
and building this therapeutic
bureaucratic scaffolding around every
single area of
lives and as a consequence these people
have less freedom less choice less sense
of themselves as active citizens in the
world so everywhere I look at the left
now particularly in Britain at Western
Europe and the US I think they are
having an incredibly destructive impact
on ordinary people's lives yeah which is
why I'm you know I still call myself
left-wing but I'm constantly conscious
of the fact that to most people out
there perfectly understandably they
think that means I'm on the wrong side
so maybe I'm fighting a losing battle
yeah I'm going to recover a sense of
what the left used to be yeah I
completely hear you brother
I like that you call that a bureaucratic
scaffolding that because it's just this
sort of fate it's almost as if they've
built this bureaucratic scaffolding on
quicksand yes really
so it's temporarily holding up this
stuff up and controlling you
that's actually the the foundation is
sinking at the same time but you know
what what proved to me that the left is
in the on the wrong side these days was
brexit so in last year 2016 seventeen
point four million British people the
largest number of British people that
have ever voted for anything in history
voted against the European Union and for
greater sovereignty greater popular
sovereignty greater Democratic control
against the EU which is an institution
which is a liberal undemocratic and also
racist it has a two-tier immigration
policy which allows freedom of movement
for largely white Europeans while at the
same time paying African dictators to
keep their people out of Europe so this
is an institution that I'm absolutely
alarmed but anyone who calls themselves
liberal or left-wing could support this
business bureau see and that's exactly
what they did
that's what they did so ordinary people
seventeen point four million of them
defied the advice of the establishment
pretty much the entire establishment was
on their knees begging us to vote to
stay in the European Union they defied
the establishment they voted against
this bureaucracy and they voted by
implication and sometimes explicitly in
what they said to pollsters they voted
for independence for more control over
there
is for less bureaucracy in their lives
right it was an incredibly positive
moment in British history in my view
it's the best thing that's happened in
Britain in 25 years
politically speaking and it was framed
as if it was some sort of racist was
framed
so what you have is the left instantly
denounced it as racist xenophobic a new
form of fascism you people have been
hoodwinked by demagogues you don't know
what you're doing you're low information
this was the term they use low
information voters idiots imbeciles you
stupid people how could you do this that
you know there are many nails in the
coffin of the left I think their failure
to understand the positive progressive
component of brexit might prove to be
the final nail because that was a very
clear instance of people doing the
things that people like us would like
them to do right take a stand against
bureaucracy and and speak for yourself
be self-governing desire to be in
control of your own life that positive
wonderful Enlightenment idea which
informed the left for at least a hundred
years after the Enlightenment and then
bit by bit they kind of lost sight of it
that's what breaks it represented and
the left's response was to call us
because I voted for breaks it was to
call us fascists that is the worst
application of the less historic
responsibility that I can remember
yeah and it's such an interesting way
that they they change words I mean they
change definitions of words fascists
yeah you were the anti fascist yes right
you were trying to take the power away
absolutely yeah
it's just they consistently do this
that's astonishing if you are in favor
of freedom of speech if you think there
should be no controls on speech if you
think democracy is preferable to
technocracy if you think these things
which we traditionally have been seen as
anti-fascist they will now call you a
fascist they've completely bastardized
that word and use it simply as a brand
to denounce people who they dislike and
you know it's particularly pronounced in
the campus culture wars where those who
defend freedom of speech most
vociferously on campus are the ones who
are called fascist which is a complete
reversal of what fascism is I was at the
in Warsaw a few weeks ago at the Museum
of the history of the Jews in Poland
which is a terrible history and what was
amazing is that there's this whole room
devoted to the Warsaw Ghetto where the
Jews were piled in before they were all
exterminated and what's amazing is that
in the Warsaw Ghetto they had no free
speech rights
none whatsoever fascist and the nazis
denied them any free speech rights and
yet these underground networks developed
and and and magazines and newspapers
emerged like mushrooms after the rain in
within the words of one of these people
in the in the warsaw ghetto you know a
risk of death they published their own
magazines they published their own
newspapers in Bunker's they stored them
under floorboards they secretly sold
them on the street and they could be
shot on the spot for doing this no my
view is that anti-fascism is freedom of
speech that's what it is in its entirety
fascism is censorship so it when I hear
all these anti far people and all these
anti-fascists going around demanding the
censorship of people they don't like
demanding the censorship of people who
they find difficult or uncomfortable
they are behaving far more like fascists
they are behaving far more like the
rulers of the Warsaw Ghetto who forbade
Jews from publishing magazines and
newspapers than they are like
anti-fascists and in my mind
anti-fascism by which I mean largely the
left yeah the left was a great warrior
against fascism was entirely about
defending freedom and it was primarily
about defending freedom of thought and
freedom of speech is the inherent
problem here with the anti fast stuff is
that the left whoever the leaders are
whether it's in Britain or in the United
States that they've coddled these ideas
for so long that they don't want to
stand up and say to anti fie you can't
do this because they don't want those
tactics used on them yes
so when everyone's concerned about
violence right now and house you know
speech and violence's are starting to
meld together
I mean anti Faiz though if there was one
organization that is creating illegal
violence in the United States the most
at the moment it's anti feh I mean the
one of the most underreported stories of
last year was outside the Democratic
National Committee as Hillary was being
nominee
and if I was basically burning it down
the mainstream media barely showed if
they show up to all these campuses and
burn everything down and break store
windows and all that the right has its
problems and I want to get to that too
because that's where you started here
you're uncomfortable with what we're
we've sort of been shifted to which I
think is really interesting but part of
the issue is the left can't stand up to
these people because they know that
they'll just take them out the way
they've taken out everyone else yeah my
view of anti-fire is that it is
absolutely the most ridiculous movement
I can think of is obscene in fact
because they present themselves as being
in the lineage of people like George
Orwell George Orwell left his incredibly
comfortable life in Britain to go to
Spain and fight physically against
fascists and risk death anti far right
now is actually a very bourgeois anti
working-class anti-democratic movement
which thinks being an anti-fascist means
getting uber into town and punching a
working-class Trump voter in the face
that is incomparable to what the
International Brigades did in Spain or
to what anti-fascists did in Greece
during the Second World War or to what
German citizens did who secretly plotted
and acted against the Nazis to commit
for them to compare compare themselves
to genuine anti-fascists in 20th century
Europe is outrageous in fact this is a
censorious snobby paternalistic
ridiculous bourgeois movement which has
completely lost sight of what it means
to be left-wing and completely lost
sight of what it means to be
anti-fascist to the extent that they
behave far more like fascists than they
do anti-fascists they are censorious
they burn things down that they find
offensive they agitate constantly to
shut down meetings they heckle people so
they cannot be heard you know they
remind me of one of the greatest things
ever written about freedom of speech was
titled a plea for free speech by
Frederick Douglas former slave of course
become abolitionist one of my favorite
figures from American history
he took part in a abolitionist meeting
in Boston and it was shut down by
hecklers the pro-slavery hecklers who
invaded this meeting and prevent
it from taking place Frederick Douglass
was so shocked by this that he wrote a
plea for free speech in which he said
free speech is the most important
freedom in the world and it's the
freedom that make makes tyrannies
tremble it's the freedom that puts
government on the backfoot it's the
freedom that keeps you as a citizen free
and active and puts authority back in
the closet where they belong
away from us and that was an argument
against the kind of thing but anti far
is doing which is invading meetings
preventing them from taking place a very
informal mob like form of censorship so
that's what they remind me off from
history they remind me of these
right-wing borderline fascistic very
questionable agitators who hated the
idea of people having freedom who hated
the idea of people speaking freely and
listening freely so the idea that anti
far is an in in any way progressive or
liberal or decent is a joke yeah all
right sort of wrap this sort of hole
first chunk together I want to talk
about this right and part of this
because you said you're sort of
uncomfortable with how this connects to
the right or where you suddenly find
yourself allied yes yeah it's not that
I'm not uncomfortable to the extent that
I can't cope with it and one of the
problems I think among left wingers who
are libertarian and I include myself in
that number I think too sometimes they
are so terrified of being called
right-wing that they actually will end
up ditching their own principles so they
won't defend free speech as much as they
would like to because they know they'll
be called they'll be compared with Cato
or reason or some other group that they
are a bit questionable about so it's not
that I'm uncomfortable to the extent
that I am going to ditch my principles I
would never ever ditch the argument for
freedom of speech I think that's the key
thing everyone has to do in the 21st
century but it's simply that I think the
reason the right has managed to colonize
the argument for liberty today in
particular the argument for freedom of
speech is not because they are 100%
behind it and you can see that in the
way in which they will agitate agitate
against the right of his lamas to
speak on campus or you know they will be
quite favorable of punishing Beyonce for
example for doing her black power dance
at the Super Bowl which in Breitbart got
very angry about and demanded an apology
for we think calm down Breitbart yeah
I'm pretty sure Beyonce doesn't do a
power yeah she doesn't do this and
that's great it's it's so they're not a
hundred percent on the side of freedom
of speech but the reason they can appear
to be is because the left has abandoned
the field and the left has turned
freedom into a dirty word and the left
has given the impression that freedom is
a right wing project this is the great
historic mistake that the left has made
it is so thoroughly abandoned the
argument for freedom of speech and for
liberty in general and for individual
autonomy which Chile used to be a
central part of radical left-wing
politics going back 150 years or so it's
so thoroughly abandoned that that the
right can now step in and say well we
are the masters of this argument so the
left has totally screwed things up and
granted the moral high ground to people
right right
so basically by not playing they've just
ceded the game
seesee okay so I understand that and I
feel you're probably you're probably
right in that but what I also found at
the exact same time is that as I've had
my own journey here and talking to
people all over the mat that I find a
lot more intellectual flexibility with
people on the right yeah so if I sit I
can sit across from people that are
pro-life while I'm pro-choice or even
some people that are against gay
marriage and I I'm gay married or you
know that I'm against the death penalty
and therefore definitely they'll at
least have an intellectual argument
about it and I see much less of that on
the left well the perfect example of
this I was supposed to speak at Oxford
University in 2014 on abortion and it
was two men it was me on one side making
the pro-choice argument I'm about as
pro-choice as you can get I mean the
other side was a right-wing man from The
Daily Telegraph which is a right-wing
newspaper who was going to make the anti
choice or pro-life argument feminists
Oxford shut it down they said it was
unacceptable for people without uterus
which is how they described us which I
thought was quite transphobic talk about
biology in that way should we tell
people
now the biologically or a woman exactly
the red jacket oh yeah I should
self-identify they threatened to shut it
down they threatened to turn up with
instruments and they didn't mean musical
instruments to prevent this debate from
taking place and Oxford too it's
mortifying shame a grid of them and
prevented the debate from taking place
what that told me was here was this
right-wing guy who's very anti choice
thinks abortion is terrible who was
willing to discuss with me and I am
incredibly pro-choice I mean right up to
the end because I believe in bodily
individual autonomy he was willing to
have that incredibly difficult debate
with me whereas the so-called left on
the campus the so called Oxford radicals
didn't want the debate to take place at
all so I think you're right at the
moment on the right there is more
intellectual flexibility there's more
openness there's more honesty and if I
was coming of political age now I would
probably go to the right and I think
that's where lots of sensible people are
going and I perfectly understand why you
self-identify as a Marxist libertarian I
tried to work this one through in my
brain for a little bit I've heard some
strange labels I've heard some words
that don't quite make sense next to each
other I'm struggling I'm struggling to
figure out how this makes sense help me
well partly I use that phrase because it
confuses people and I think it's good to
confuse people or to make them think you
know how can this be possible how can
these two terms go together and that's
what people say and that's what people
start to think about but the way I see
it you know I'm always with Marxism and
the radical left I'm like people are
with rock bands always say I prefer the
early stuff you know before they went
rubbish and awful yeah and that's how I
am with the left
I like the early stuff if you go right
back to where the word left comes from
which is on the the French Revolutionary
National Assembly the people who sat on
the left side of the National Assembly
in the late seventeen hundreds that's
why they're called the left those people
were incredibly Pro reason Pro Liberty
that's what they were fighting for Pro
autonomy that's what drove them and
that's what drove the Left including the
radical left for at least six or seven
decades after that right through to Marx
and angles and the
of mid eighteen hundreds writers and
radicals who published manifestos and so
on they were driven by a desire for
greater liberty in life and people
forget that now because of course we
have this horrors of Stalinism
the 20th century left is generally
speaking a disaster from Stalinism right
through to the left support of the
welfare stay and it's growing
bureaucracy towards the left we have now
which is indistinguishable
unrecognizable rather from the left that
existed 150 or 200 years ago but if you
read you know when Marx was in his 20s
he wrote the best defenses of press
freedom you will ever read the Prussian
authorities were seeking to clamp down
on the Free Press and Marx wrote these
wonderful essay saying look of course
the press is rubbish and tells lies and
veers to the right and can be extreme
but it must its liberty must always be
defended if you read the communist
manifesto which I recommend to all your
viewers they must read the communist
manifesto the first nine or ten pages
are devoted to praising the capitalist
class praising them for the wonders of
what they created the new system of
production they brought in they're using
credit Marx and Engels use incredibly
unpeel anguish to talk about the
smashing down of backward cultures and
the spread of free trade and capitalist
trade into all areas of the world and
the way it creates the opportunity for a
universal culture and more dynamism and
more Liberty and more choice so they
spend a long time praising the
developments that had been brought about
it's hard to believe actually I don't
think I've read it really since college
yes there are to believe and it's always
worth reminding people of that because
the idea because the problem we face
today is that we have a left that has
utterly forgotten its political origins
and its political origins boiled down to
their essence was how can we make
mankind even freer than the capitalist
era had already made it so there was a
recognition that under capitalism we had
greater freedom and choice than we did
under any system before that right
that's interesting because there seems
to be no recognition no now it's like
that is the evil thing that's right
which is always come
from people that live in actually the
freest accessorize on earth but you know
the problem with anti capitalism today
is that it's incredibly it hates all the
things about capitalism that the early
Marx is actually quite liked which is
international trade the
internationalization of trade even the
consumer society in the Grundy's Marx
wrote about the wonders of advertising
and and he has this wonderful passage
where he talks about how great it is the
capitalists are always using chatter and
trying to tempt us towards buying their
products he said that's one of the good
civilizing things about capitalist
society and of course economic growth
the fact that people can buy more stuff
those things were were the aspects of
capitalism that the early radicals
actually liked but they didn't think it
was enough mm-hmm and it's those things
that the modern-day anti capitalist hate
because what anti-can while they do it
from their eyes while they do it they
say how much they hate it on their
iPhones yeah but they they actually it's
not so much capitalism they hate as
mankind's ambitions and his you know his
interference with nature or his
arrogance this kind of it's it's really
human hubris as they see it that they
are agitated by not capitalism itself so
it's a very backward reactionary
movement not at all like the early
leftist yeah so linking that with your
sort of Marxist libertarian with just
those two words next week so in effect
you're I get what you're saying here
you're you're sort of putting those two
words together just to get a little
conversation going ya know get a little
bit of look at a little bit of history
and understand that not everything about
Marxism at least at the beginning was
completely evil and all that but but in
effect I think you're making the great
case for classical liberalism if I do
say so myself right now probably I am
yeah because I think the crisis we face
at the moment is incredibly serious and
that crisis is a a very serious crisis
of freedom and a crisis of progress and
a crisis of humanism that's the problem
we face at the moment we fate we live in
a modern society which has lost faith in
itself a modern society which has lost
faith in its found
values which are individual if you look
at the founding values of modern society
going back 400 300 years or whatever it
is individual autonomy freedom of speech
the right of people to pursue happiness
to live independently to make choices
for themselves the right to trade all
those things which were incredibly
radical ideas when they first came about
and remain radical ideas now in fact as
anyone who stands up for freedom of
speech or due process or free trade will
soon discover they are still incredibly
dangerous controversial ideas even today
the pursuit of happiness what a radical
idea incredibly record live you're right
and you know what I love about the
phrase the pursuit of happiness is that
it implies that you have to find the
happiness for yourself and you know we
have a lot of Pro happiness movements at
the moment in fact in Europe it's now a
government institution to increase
happiness levels in society and in fact
the United Nations what is that yes what
does anyone over yeah in in Britain we
have happiness advisors to the
government and the United Nations now
does this Happiness index measures Iran
actually this right the happiness of
individual nations and how it might be
increased which actually brings to mind
Huxley's brave new world because in
brave new world the terrifying
authoritarian state is obsessed with
making people happy yeah because it
thinks it can just manage people's
emotions or tweak people's emotions and
and increase their joy of life but the
great thing about the phrase the right
to pursue happiness is that it says we
trust you and we're going to leave you
to carve out your path in life of
yourself and to discover what makes you
happy to use your autonomy and your
choice and your freedom and your
interaction with other people to
discover happiness so I've always
favored that the use of those words
together the pursuit of happiness is so
much more preferable to this attempt to
make us happy which is always just an
authoritarian idea do you think that
most people in Europe are actually
jealous of the extra protections that we
have here you know that our bill of
right to me the United States
Constitution
is probably the greatest document ever
created I mean I truly believe that the
freedoms that it protects that it
guarantees and protects this is as good
as it gets the Bill of Rights the
Declaration of Independence all of these
things life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness are you guys a little extra
jealous of us
we are jealous I mean in France they
have similar documents the rights of man
and in fact both of these things come in
some large part from my hero Thomas
Paine who's obviously from England from
the Norfolk a radical who had to leave
England because he was threatened to
with death because of what he believed
comes to America works with the American
revolutionaries writes common sense
which argues for America to break from
Britain then he goes to France and helps
to draft the Rights of Man which is
another great document of that
Revolutionary era which also says people
have are born with rights and you may
not interfere with them so I I as a Brit
or an Irish Brit I am a bit jealous of
what America and France have which are
these founding documents which guarantee
Liberty but you know another part of me
thinks they're not quite enough and I
always think this when I come to America
I always have this conflicting emotion
where on the one hand I am incredibly
jealous of the First Amendment and I see
it I've recently been in Boston and you
see it chipped into stone yeah and I
love it and I take photographs of it
wherever I say I think these are the
greatest 45 words ever written Congress
may not interfere with freedom of speech
freedom of the press freedom of religion
freedom of assembly what that is the
best idea you could ever have so I love
that but at the same time I think it's
not enough and I the reason I know it's
not enough because in the u.s. people
self-censor they stop themselves from
speaking people are prevented from
speaking on campus and I guess my issue
with the First Amendment is that it
stops the government from interfering
with freedom of speech and that's great
the government should never do that but
it doesn't have anything to say and
maybe it's right that it doesn't have
anything to say about the bigger problem
we face today which is informal forms of
censorship so at the New York law school
a couple of weeks ago is debating Angus
Johnston who's this anti
left-wing academic in New York and he
says he's a first-rate an actual
anti-fascist or he's an anti-fog a
anti-rock yeah yeah yeah yeah and he
describes himself as a First Amendment
absolutist however he supports the new
forms of censorship on campus like
trigger warnings or shutting down
meetings that are too extreme and so on
and as he said this I thought you know
what there actually isn't necessarily a
contradiction between those two things
because you can support the restriction
on any government intervention in
censorship while also given a green
light towards the more informal Center
for the the tyranny of custom as John
Stuart Mill called it which I think has
a more insidious role to play so what
I'm saying is I completely agree with
you that this document was found in
document of this nation was probably the
most wonderful moment in political
history so far however what I think
we've discovered in the decades since
then and I think we've particularly
discovered it in this young century is
that it's not quite enough you know yes
learn at hand said this one of your
great jurists 50 or 60 or 70 years ago I
can't remember learn at hand said it's
there's no point having the defense of
freedom of speech written on paper if it
doesn't live in men's hearts and that's
the problem we face now America has it
written down on paper and that's great
but at the moment it doesn't live in the
people's hearts and that's where the
work has to be done yeah it's such an
interesting distinction because it's
almost like it's so interesting you're
saying these are the best 45 words ever
and I think because of their passion for
individual freedom they probably felt we
can't make another we can't have another
ten servants you know to me like the
bike whatever those words would be to
put the onus back on you the spirit of
it lives already in those documents so
it's like we can't add more but I do see
your point it's interesting but also if
they had added something about informal
censorship that could have been a
problem in itself right because they
could have been clamping down on mobs
and the right of people to gather in
public and say well I don't think you
should say this and that could have been
seen as a form of censorship in itself
so
a very difficult situation and I'm not
saying that the bill of rights should or
even could have any kind of stipulation
against the informal censorship but I
think there's a real great historic
responsibility on the shoulders of those
of us who believe in Liberty genuinely
believe in Liberty to say that opposing
the state is not always enough and this
is where I think lots of right-wing
libertarians come unstuck
because right-wing libertarians are
obsessed and some in some ways rightly
obsessed with the role of government and
they think you know we're charge too
much tax and they shouldn't take away
our guns and they shouldn't undermine
our free speech and I agree with all of
that but they often have a very myopic
reading of the crisis of Liberty so I
think it's simply a function of
government and they are often as a
consequence insensitive to new forms of
authoritarianism informal forms of
authoritarianism
for example twitch hunts groups of
people that general sense of conformism
that now surround certain issues where
which means that huge numbers of people
out there who we never hear from I'm not
saying what they feel and and there was
a European philosopher whose name might
forget who says that this gives rise to
a spiral of silence so that people just
quite instinctively pick up that they're
not supposed to say this in public and
they kind of disappear into a spiral of
silence and what happens as John Stuart
Mill said again is that eccentricity of
thought becomes more rare mm-hmm daring
thought becomes rarer and the problem
there is that progress only comes
through taking intellectual risks
progress only comes through people
saying what they shouldn't say for
example that the earth is not the center
of the universe right when when that was
said that was the most radical
controversial thing you could have said
and if if it was said today if it was
this climate you'd be hounded a saying
right you'd be no platform you'd be safe
spaced it's only through having the
space in which people feel at some level
whatever the risks they should say what
they think that you can have human
progress at all you know the point I
made in a speech
Oxford University recently is that every
single progressive leap forward whether
it's of the technological variety of the
liberal variety of all the social
variety comes from someone defying
conformist dicta going against the grain
saying something that they probably
shouldn't have said and the the more
that we feel we cannot do that the more
not only are we silencing ourselves and
diminishing public discussion but we are
also limiting the possibility of
discovering new ways of understanding
the world that's the real danger yeah
and it's so interesting because I'm
listening to you say all that and at the
same time I'm thinking I don't think
there's anything they could have added
yeah or should have added that would
have done it yeah but it's an
interesting intellectual exercise like
could they have tipped us off a little
bit more in that way and maybe one day
we can reanimate them and have that
described well I think that it is a
difficult one and I think that that cake
their key concern and it's it's great
that this was their key concern was
limiting the power of government yeah
and it's perfectly understandable that
they did you know most American
colonists or many American colonists
were people who had to flee Europe
because they couldn't practice religion
freely and they couldn't speak freely
and so they had to go to this whole new
nation and start doing it there so it's
understandable that their great concern
was restricting the power of government
and let's be incredibly grateful that
they did that yeah so maybe they're
pressing concern wasn't with more
informal forms of censorship or maybe
they just thought that they couldn't
actually put that into words without
becoming accidentally censorious
themselves yeah I suspect it's the
latter yeah so I think the onus is now
on us to say thank you that's fantastic
and we agree with you that Congress
should never do those things but at the
same time we are now going to make the
argument for freedom of speech in
everyday life as a real lived felt
experience rather than something that's
just granted to us by a document yeah
well I guess that's what we're doing huh
all right so we're doing okay then I
want to shift a little bit from free
speech and just hit a couple other
hot-button issues you know I read most
of your columns but this first one I'm
actually not sure if you've written on
where do you stand
the the monument situation that we're
going through right now the tearing down
of material I think is crazy yeah I
think it's Year Zero stuff I think it's
quite all well Ian this attempted
erasure of history in a very
undemocratic fashion I think it's
hysterical and deluded and I think what
it really points to which is is the
scary thing is the expansion of the safe
space beyond campuses into everyday life
and so what you have now is a situation
where not only do people on campus say
well we don't want this book or we don't
want this speaker or we don't want Dave
Rubin or we don't want this statue get
them of our campus what's happening now
is that that idea is spreading into non
campus parts of public life and I think
this actually points to the real danger
of not getting a handle on the crisis on
campus because that you are creating a
new generation which thinks that their
self-esteem is so sacred that anything
which interferes with it whether it's a
word or a book or an idea or a statue
must be destroyed and so we are creating
this incredibly narcissistic censorious
generation who presume with supreme
arrogance that anything that they don't
like or which offends them should be
shunned from public life and unless we
tackle that culture now I think this
whole situation of tearing things down
silencing things rearranged in public
life so that it never offends these kind
of usually quite upper-middle class
arrogant groups of people that's going
to get worse and worse and to me that
the tearing down of statues actually
brings to mind what the Taliban did in
Afghanistan we are ripped down the
statues of the huge Buddhas yeah which
had been around for thousands of years
and which were an important part of
Afghanistan's culture or Isis in Syria
and Iraq and Syria and their argument of
course if you read what Isis says in its
magazine their argument is that these
are offensive statues they offend the
ISIS view of life so I see very little
difference between that kind of
extremism and the more the kind of
so-called left extremism that we have
over here yeah and it's so interesting
because I'm with you a hundred percent I
am against taking all
things down I I would argue that if you
want to put a counter you're not to put
a counter monument per se you could put
a counter plaque yeah that explains the
history more I think maybe a wooden I
was asked this question once at a
college and a student and I said I'm
against all that a student said well
could you move some of them to museums I
think maybe I could have that
conversation for a while but it's only a
small group of people that actually go
to museums and you know the so there's a
problem there but I'm basically with you
but even further I think if we allow
this to go any further it's already gone
too far right I mean even I don't know
if you heard this one too here this one
about a week ago that they took at
George Washington's Church in Alexandria
Virginia they took a plaque off of him
because there was also a plaque of
robert e lee who went to the same church
i said well for taking the robert lee
down we have to take those George
Washington was a slave owner and it's
like this is this is insane no I mean
this is this is a guy who gave up his
power as a commander in the army right
and then became the first president all
that but to me the real issue is they
will never stop that's that's it this
will never end they will literally take
down the Washington Monument and the
Jefferson Memorial raised the houses of
these people and churches and all of
that but you know what I completely
agree and it's the slippery slope
because once you green like the removal
of robert e lee statutes for example and
most people will agree he's a at least a
controversial figure in history in my
view i would have been completely on the
other side on the side of the right so
it certainly seems like we're defending
yeah buddy Lee and that is nothing so I
if I'd been around then I would have
been with the north I would have been
fighting the Confederacy and so on that
I hope goes without saying but the thing
is that once you green like the removal
of any statue that a small group of
people considers to be offensive because
of their historical attitudes of these
people then there's no stopping it and
and the thing that's really shocked me
is the attacks on Jefferson because as
far as I'm concerned Jefferson is one of
the greatest figures in history I mean
he's my personal hero of all hero and
you know you know of course he made
mistakes and one of his mistakes was not
to grapple with the institution of
slavery and he didn't know what to do
about it or he was reluctant to do
anything about it and there were other
people at the same time he was saying we
need to sort this situation out yes he
made mistakes but
his contribution to history's
contribution to progress his
contribution to Liberty overshadows
anything that these idiots smashing down
statues will achieve in a million years
so that's what's terrifying when it
moves to people like Jefferson because
what that suggests is there's this
insatiable attitude this insatiable
desire to tear down the statues or
likenesses of anyone in history who
didn't completely share our views yeah
and you know who that includes everyone
in here everyone that includes everyone
that includes the women who brought in
the rights of birth control
many of whom were eugenicist or had
problems with poor families and black
families that includes early leftists
who made great breakthroughs for
working-class people but may not have
had a great attitude to women for
example everyone in history had
different attitudes to us and everyone
in 40 years down the line will think
that we had bad attitudes too well
that's well that's what I want people to
understand you know Barack Obama when he
ran the first time was against gay
marriage yes there are many videos of
him saying marriages between a man and a
woman bla bla well if we allow all this
to continue and then attitudes change
and then 40 years from now Sarah's gonna
watch a video of Barack Obama saying
marriage is between a man and a woman
and attitudes will have changed and
progresses will of won and then what are
they gonna do they're gonna blow up the
Obama library that they're building
right actually that's right and and so
it's this is the problem with I think it
was a child Menken who made this point
the censorship and authoritarianism need
to be stopped at the very start because
they will always spin out of control and
and he said the difficult thing there is
that that means you have to defend
scoundrels you have this great word you
have to defend scoundrels because
authoritarianism is first end of
scoundrels and you must defend their
freedom because otherwise you will be
screwed to at some point that's exactly
how I feel when I see people tearing
down Robert
Ely I have to defend that scoundrel or
at least the statue of that scoundrel in
order to preserve the idea the public
space is not simply something that you
can rearrange to your tastes history is
all around us this is the great thing
about living in an open free civilized
society you are surrounded by history
you're surrounded by the pictures or the
names of people who in some
I contributed to the society live in
whether for good or for ill that's the
great thing and it's always changing and
shifting and and and and you feel like
you're in a living Society this idea
that that historic those historic
representation should be erased so you
don't feel offended would turn society
into this bland authoritarianism Kafka s
nightmare yeah and you know the other
thing is that it's also incredibly
paternalistic because one of the
arguments they use is that these statues
are particularly offensive to minority
groups so Oxford University they want to
take down a statue of Cecil Rhodes who
was a British imperialist and the
argument they use is that it's an
environmental microaggression so they
say that black black steel is a cannot
walk past this statue without feeling
that wounded I think that's racist yeah
I think it is racist to suggest that
black students have less capability of
negotiating public life than whites
young so that's the soft bigotry of low
soft bigotry of low expectations and
that's a recurring argument with these
new so-called leftists which is a lot of
what they're doing in fact rehabilitates
the racial imagination rehabilitates the
racial divide so that they end up
arguing in fact in favor of black
fragility in a way the racists might
have done 100 years ago and so I have a
problem with the removal of statues on
that level to yeah you know it's funny
I've mentioned this a couple of times
one of the moments when I really
realized how messed up this ideology was
was a couple years ago and I heard Oprah
say that well we just need these old
racist people to die did you hear that
my chance and I just thought god that's
first of these people who grew up in a
completely different world who are
complex individuals and and we all are
just people of our time with flaws and
all of those things but Oprah you're
going to be old one day and out of touch
and should we just start exterminating
people I mean should we be like you know
once you get 65 your ideas are so old
we're actually just gonna boo you I mean
I don't want to give any ideas you know
because I will jump on it one of the
problems I have at the moment
I think one of the worst trends of our
time is this sack realization of youth
this cult of youth and this demonization
of people over 60 or even over 50 who
might have different attitudes or
different experiences or different views
of the world that is incredibly
pronounced in both America and Britain
we've really seen it in Britain after
the brexit vote brexit was more popular
among older people than it was among
younger people so we've seen lots of
people arguing that maybe if you're over
65 you shouldn't have the right to vote
because you won't live in society for as
long as someone who's 21 a profoundly
anti-democratic argument a profoundly
anti-human argument it really
dehumanizes older generations and that's
another issue I have with this kind of
new authoritarianism which is this
implicit suggestion that the older
generations are a problem either to be
re-educated or rethought or ideally
brushed aside ignore them don't listen
to them and part of the culture wars
part of this creation of to America so
you have the good America which is
liberal and PC and right on and
intersectional and usually quite young
and you have the bad America which is
traditional and interested in Liberty
maybe a bit older it may be a bit more
working-class the creation of these two
Americas is really dangerous because it
demonizes a whole swath of the
population and it tends to demon alike
demonize those who are rural elderly
traditional who believe in the right of
free speech and the right to own guns
who believe that the Constitution should
be taken seriously in its entirety those
people are now seen as almost subhuman
and you can call them fascists and
racists and xenophobes and white
supremacists even if they are none of
those things so that the ease with which
whole groups of people can now be
demonized as another sign I think of how
unhinged that kind of supposedly left
culture has become yeah well I gotta
tell you man I knew I was gonna enjoy
sitting down with you and you know
because I read what you do and I and I
love what spike is doing and I've you
know you guys are out there touring and
all of that stuff I knew this was gonna
be good but I feel like we got a good
handle on some of this stuff in a way
that it for as much as I do it I think
sometimes there's some you know people
always have more questions but I think
this is going to be one of the ones that
I can link people back to and say you
really want to unpack this stuff this is
it so it's been a pleasure let's do some
colleges together absolutely all right
do that we will talk about that brendan
is wise enough not to be on the Twitter
so you can't follow him there but you
can go - spike - online comm for more
[Music]